I don't know why but I always enjoyed
listening to Christmas carols maybe it's
due to their connection with my favorite
season or maybe they're just good songs
I don't know but with that said if I had
to pick my favorite I will probably have
to go with Good King Wenceslas
after all it's very well-known even
being sung by the soldiers in the
Christmas trees but to specify when I
said Good King Wenceslas I meant that I
like to translate a Czech version not
the English one but wait hold on
translated into Czech its inventor
Schlosser Czech king hmm yeah he is well
not this one or this one or this one not
any of them in fact the King we called
the good king wenceslas or also known as
st. Wenceslas the patron saint of Czech
lands lived in the 10th century and was
the first King of Bohemia every to be
called Wenceslas right I digress now
that we know which whence a slice of
Bohemia the song is talking about why
isn't the original Cairo in check well
for Dad we'll have to do some extensive
digging as the answer isn't as simple as
you may think so to start off with we
will have to skip st. Wenceslas actual
life at the 10th century as the origin
of the Cairo surprisingly doesn't start
with him it was in fact during the high
middle ages around the early 13th
century when the melody and the Turkic
metre of the song was created but it
wasn't a Christmas Carol it was a Latin
spring song called temples Addis Florida
which talked about blooming flowers and
the coming of warmth right after the
frost of winter the song wasn't written
down for much of its early existence so
no one really knows where it came from
but this is how it sounded like oddity
[Music]
no me beat them so pretty much very
similar to Ventus last Carol today just
with different words continue on from
their tempo Saudis Florida was finally
written down in Finland around the 16th
century into a book called P I can t
honest this book which was a collection
of multiple medieval songs eventually
found its way to England where in the
19th century it came into the hands of
John Mason Neal he was known in England
as a devout Christian hymn writer and
especially a hymn translator of old
Latin medieval texts and this is where
tempos out of flora don't comes into
play as he's the one who took the melody
of that song and used it for a Christmas
song he wrote called Good King Wenceslas
he then published a song in 1853 which
was met with mixed results however over
time it became one of the most well
known Christmas carols not just in the
english-speaking world but also in the
rest of Europe so when does Chuck come
into play to any of this well if you
look closely on the Wikipedia article
for the Good King mitosis Carol there's
a sentence mentioning that according to
older check sources Neil's lyrics are
translation of a poem by Czech poet VAT
Slava Ali Swoboda written in Czech
German and Latin why those three
languages you asked well because Bohemia
was part of the austro-hungarian Empire
and if he wrote something in Czech he
also had to read it at least in German
and Latin so other people and the Empire
could read it but I digress again
continue on from there in true Wikipedia
fashion when you click the source for
the sentence the page doesn't exist does
this mean that the Czechs just made this
up so they could lay some sort of a
hypothetical claim to a popular English
Christmas Carol about their old king
well that's what I thought after
googling for the original poem written
by Basso and only coming across numerous
pages like this one on duolingo where
even people from trigger public we're
unable to find the original poem with my
luck being no different I was almost
about to decide that the poem was just
made up check propaganda and leave it at
that but then I came across this book
written and check in 1902 where on the
page 208 the writer complaints about
bats while not getting any credit for
writing the original good king wenceslas
poem in 1847 which would be 6 years
before
Neal's publication of his Carole the
writer goes on to cite his source where
he names the poem and German sankt
Wenzel un po d Winnie which means st.
wenceslas and Pavini
whatever dad is but now I have the
source so I can just plug this into
Google and find the original well turns
out no because even mighty Google has no
idea what the source means even if you
just put in the suppose a German name of
the poem nothing turns out so now I'm
back to square one as the Austrian Czech
chairman and Oxford online Library
Archives along with Google turned out
nothing when you type into supposed name
of the poem outside of that one book
that is referencing it but at this point
I'm not willing to give up just yet I
decided to change my approach from
searching just for the poem to searching
for the author of the poem although at
that moment I realized I completely
forgot to address the problem every
austro-hungarian scholar faces and that
is multiple names and variations of
names for one thing so when it came to
the author of our suppose it poem turns
out that he had 15 plus different
variation of his name these variations
were enlarged but when dealing with
library databases a single letter change
can make a big difference plus the
author's first name that slow is checked
name for which the English mentis loss
is derived from so I'm searching for a
poem with a king named Ventus loss and
the writer named Vince's loss or
Wenceslas and VAT slow or that slow and
bad so 9 and heist pencil me a mana
amoeba slow name uh never Wenceslaus huh
oh she said obj let's go back to the
drawing board now we know there's
multiple variations for not just the
name of the author but also the poem so
we could have just been searching for
the bad variation of the poet's name I
quickly write out some plausible name
variations and go back to the author
mentioned online databases I still have
no luck finding the exact poem but I do
find numerous amounts of writings
mentioning or referencing the 1847
inventors last poem I also find that
Ponte bean is in a weird German word but
actual name of Kings favourite servant
in the 10th century I even managed to
find the bookkeeping zuv either a
product-based publisher or just a
bookseller
selling the sank 20 slump odevened poem
for 10 austro-hungarian crowns in 1847
now finally convinced the actual poem
exists I'm pleased to finally find it so
at this point it's time to turn to my
last plan which is searching for all the
different variations of the author's
name and then looking if one of the
works that come up is the Good King
Wenceslas poem I go to the Austrian
National Library first and nothing I
didn't go to the Czech National Library
and after a few tries of different name
variations I finally find the Czech and
German version of the poem but I can't
see them because there's no digitized
version I can however schedule a meeting
and fly to Prague to see the works with
my own eyes apparently this is so weird
you complain for a check not getting
credit for creating the original good
king wenceslas poem but then hide the
actual original poems from anyone
reading it you don't have to take
pictures of the originals if it will
ruin them at least write them down on a
blog post or something so we can at
least see what the original poem says
unless it doesn't actually exist
yes there are many references citing the
poem but we never seen the original
maybe this is just a weird cycle where
everybody references something that
doesn't actually exist and it got to
such a point that Czech National Library
mentions the poems under the writers
creations without really looking if they
actually have them brushing it off as an
oh it's in just an old pal old book
somewhere maybe no that would be crazy
I would never happen right well actually
in this case it didn't happen how do I
know because even though I haven't seen
the original poem a week later I managed
to find an 1847 Austrian yearbook for
teachers parents and educators which
along with math problems and other
things that teachers would like has the
German version of the Battle of Eylau
Swoboda sank 20 Slav on Ponyville poem
published that same year now finally
that we have the poem we can look if neo
actually just translated but sauce
or created its own song well we can say
for sure just from the first Lucas that
Neil didn't just straight-up translate
the poem into English and that was that
this is because Neil Skaro has only five
stanzas whereas Fatso's poem has three
verses to get a numbering in twenty six
stanzas plus Neil scarole has an
alternative rhyming scheme as opposed to
versus poem which has two different
rhyming schemes starting with a couplet
which then switches into an alternate
this means without alterations versus
poem couldn't even be sunk to the good
king wenceslas tune however when you
start looking at the context of the poem
that's where things get interesting
both work start off with a clear moonlit
night with snow on the ground both have
a king looking out of his window both
have the king spotting some poor person
/ people struggling in the winter night
both have the king deciding he needs to
help to set poor person / people both
have a servant helping the king carry
wine and food and wood to the poor
person / people both have the servant
struggling to move any longer in the
cold and both have the king telling you
the servant to walk in his footsteps as
it will be easier for him in conclusion
it seems too confidential for there to
be so many similarities between these
two works
therefore it's safe to say that Neil
definitely took the story of Good King
Wenceslas from vassal spawn after dad he
shortened it altered it to fit the tune
and published it without crediting or
even mentioning glad so at all so next
time when you hear the good king
wenceslas Cairo you'll know it's a story
about a 10th century bohemian King from
a 19th century Czech poet altered by an
English hymn writer to fit a 13th
century spring tune I have promised for
a while now that I'll do a Q&A when I
reach 10k subscribers and since it looks
like I should reach that milestone in
January I've decided that my January
video is going to be a Q&A so if you
want to ask me a question there's a link
to a Google Form in the description
please don't leave your questions in the
comment section or on Twitter I will
only answer the questions from the
Google Form I hope you enjoyed my
Christmas special video please consider
supporting me on patreon and also I have
a youtube history podcast with cookie
dough you can listen to you Merry
Christmas
you
[Music]